David, what do you think will happen when
Donald Trump is no longer president, whenever
that is, and he loses presidential immunity
from prosecution?
So I'll answer the question.
Remember this whole idea of immunity?
It's not been tested.
It really is more of a memo that the Justice
Department has put out saying we as a policy
don't believe in indicting or prosecuting
a sitting president.
But here's the way that I imagine it will
go.
If you were waiting around imagining that
Donald Trump is going to be criminally charged
and perp walked and tried and potentially
face time in prison.
Forget it.
I mean, we you know, it just doesn't happen
to presidents.
Trump has violated the emoluments clause.
All sorts of different financial crimes.
I get it.
But if you're waiting for the perp walk, I
would not hold my breath.
Let's just remove Trump in November.
The country and the world will be much better
for it.
Now, that being said, there are active pending
criminal investigations in the southern district
of New York.
The New York attorney general, there is almost
no doubt whatsoever that whenever Trump's
national nightmare is over and the mango menace
is gone, could be in a few months, could be
in four months and a year before years and
a few months, rather.
His businesses are very likely to be charged
with all sorts of criminal violations for
financial improprieties.
I don't imagine that Donald Trump is actually
going to take the fall or be the one who gets
charged and certainly not convicted.
There are likely going to be underlings that
will get plea deals.
Who knows?
Trump is not going to be convicted.
I would be shocked if he is even charged in
those financial crimes.
It's going to be financial irregularities.
Could be anything from money laundering, misappropriation
of funds, all sorts of stuff like that.
Now, once Trump is gone, he can be charged
with whatever a prosecutor wants to charge
him with.
But there is another element to this.
It's not just the general reality that presidents
don't get criminally charged once they leave
office.
How do you get a jury that any legal system
would say is a fair one?
You can't ask for a change of venue because
it was the president of the United States.
You either have people who voted for the guy
on the jury who are not going to be impartial
jurors.
You have people who actively dislike the guy
who are not going to be impartial jurors.
And even if you and I can imagine a sort of
a political person that says, listen, I didn't
vote either way and I don't really pay attention
to politics.
How do you actually get a at an unnamed partial
jury of Trump's peers in general as a president,
but particularly when he is as polarizing
as Donald Trump has been?
So I don't mean to say that this suggests
Trump has not committed crimes.
I don't mean to say that Donald Trump should
not be prosecuted when he's gone.
But what I am telling you is the perp walk
is not happening.
The best we can hope for is that there are
some financial crimes with which Trump's businesses
are charged and maybe somebody will take a
hit.
We don't really.